all right Maddy Maddy where'd you grow
up where you from originally
oh I've grown up in a couple different
states Arizona Oregon Wyoming and here
tell me about your childhood yet you had
both your parents when you were child um
I didn't have a childhood really I was
always getting left places I'm a
biological parents so when I was taken
from them foster care and getting
adopted wasn't really good and then the
adoption family and I kind of got really
on bad turns and I came out here
how'd your biological parents lose you
um my mom's a drug addict and a
prostitute and then my dad is in prison
see you into the foster system
at what age five how was that experience
um it wasn't good I just went to one
home the first day I went to one home
and then they didn't want us so then I
went to the next home that home ended up
adopting us two years later and until I
was 12 I lived with them before I went
to mental health hospitals after that I
was sent to those my brother shows he
was my only option and I didn't know him
before I went to go lieutenant and then
I came out here how was the time you
spent with your brother um it was okay
I'm he was better than being at home
with the foster parents but it wasn't
the best but it was so better any abuse
you're kidding oh yeah have had such
little Buse and physical abuse and
emotional abuse
I'm the foster parent yeah what age was
that going on um from eight years old
all the way up until I was 15 I was
getting abused by the mom she'd hit me
and
she always say that she didn't love me
or other stuff and the dad and third
grade he cited sexual abuse abusing
until I was in seventh grade and then
you went on your own at what age um 15
where'd you go out here to LA even
homeless since when June 24th 2019 so
you had a job for a while yeah how old
are you I'm 16 and a half
oh you're 16 you look older yeah I get
that a lot I would not have guessed you
to be 16 so you have mental health
issues as well um I don't I mean it's
hard not to with the childhood you yeah
I tried everything possible to get out
of the house
cuz I couldn't take it anymore couldn't
stay there and keep getting hit or
abused and it was really starting away
on me so I started cutting myself and I
overdosed when I was 12 I don't whole
bunch of pills like eight nine different
kind of pills and social workers in
Oregon didn't do anything because they
deemed the house safe sorry so did you
go to high school at all um yeah how
into the first year of high school 9th
grade and I'm a little above ninth grade
but other than that I haven't continued
back up where do you say now you're in a
tent yeah they're using drugs at all um
sometimes I do but I've looked up a lot
and seeing a lot of people change on it
and the new drug that fentanyl that came
out ages I'm starting to slow down but
sometimes I relapse
so using that I get bored oh no I don't
use that enough what do you use most of
the time I use crystal and I smoke it I
used to shoot it up but I almost died
from that they're using any other drugs
heroin or crack I use heroin one time it
was not my drug and I used crack one
time but I didn't feel anything from it
how are you supporting yourself what do
you do for money now
recycling um I also have family out here
and they're not like my blood family
there's just people I've met out here
who have watched over me and taking care
of me
have you had any bad things happen to
you while you've been down here on Skid
Row um you seem like you might be a
little more vulnerable target than most
folks yeah people like just because I'm
white that makes me a target and people
really race this out here even than
being adults I like not being rude I'm
more of an adult than a lot of people
out here because you like to say drama
and it's just entertainment for them
I've been sexually abused out here what
kind of stuff has happened here um guys
touching me in my sleep some guys coming
on me I had a boyfriend my first
boyfriend he'll we used to beat me up
every day do you find yourself doing
things outside of what you'd normally
allow yourself to do since you've been
down here I think the only thing is
really smoking and maybe uh eating food
that I wouldn't normally eat on a
everyday basis but I'm being out here
has made me also become more grown
because I see how people are and I do
not want to be my final resting spot out
here but you still have hope for a
better life mm-hmm but I know that the
foster care system is not mine um it's
not the right choice for me so I know if
I could just push through this until I
could just make it so I'm 18 and then do
online school and get it at zero and
then get a job in that'd be great you
know cuz you don't you don't seem to fit
down here no you know you don't seem to
be meant for this but at the same time I
have people who make me fit in like they
they just support like they don't like
me being down here but they always have
my back and everything so family out
here yeah getting away from this
neighborhood would probably be a healthy
thing for you
I I don't know if I could do that
because people out here who I've
connected with who are good for me but
at the same time that's the only part Oh
scare me I would never be able to see
them again
do you feel like this life on Skid Row
is is a good fit for you a lot of people
feel like this is their home eventually
yeah it's home it is home it does grow
on you but everybody hates it the
gangbangers they all hate it and they
regret going into the gangs but they
still do it because once you're in a
gang you can't really go backwards and
it's really hard like three days worth
it rains and there's no food you go five
days without food soaking wet with no
clothes but it will all come to you
eventually
yeah depends on what your hustle is a
lot of people hustle and they ho or they
sell drugs or kill people it all depends
on the person when were you first
introduced to drugs hmm
when did you first get introduced to
drugs morning around 28 27 Oh June last
year
um within the first month I started
shooting up and I did two back-to-back
shots and almost died and that and that
scared me enough not to do shots anymore
are you scared that maybe if you spend
too much time down here you'll have
changed um I've changed a lot since
being down here I've learned more about
myself
and things I didn't like like anger but
I guess that's a lot about being hurt
and I just put up with a lot like I get
a lot of bullying and there's a lot of
not fitting in that it doesn't help and
people are scared because my age but I
have also change in a good way to I'm
just scared that this place is and they
don't want over J succeed or you usually
end up following the crowd and I'm
afraid that I might die out here if I'm
not strong enough or if I do the wrong
mistake on accident because I matter
something but other than that I'm not
really afraid of being out here are you
afraid of maybe a change in your
personality you know your values might
change about being down here over time
to a certain point you might become a
harder tougher version of the softer
kinder girl you once were yeah to a
certain point yes but also it has opened
my eyes cuz the world is a very cruel
place like everyone's different but it's
also teaching me a lot to like see right
through the [ __ ] of people and lying
and I'll turn the motives that people
have cuz a lot of people tell you
something to tell you it to get what
they want out of the situation instead
of what is best for you and the same
that you are born alone in you die alone
it's very true but you can't live life
alone but you can't also rely on there
everybody a lot all right Maddie well
thank you for coming in and talking with
me good luck with the getting out of
Skid Row and getting your life together
it'd be really nice to see you find
something that takes you away from here
and get your life back on track if it
was a chance that I could get like
schooling and still be out here and my
sorrow and my job
legally I do all of it I just live on my
own
so I could get my a real apartment
instead of an SRO all right Maddie well
good luck and I wish the best for you
thank you
you